JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, TO PRODUCE
ONE BILL THAT REPUBLICANS CAN
GET BEHIND AND THE PRESIDENT CAN
SIGN INTO LAW.
>> Laura: CHAIRMAN, THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
I JUST BOOK MOMENTS AGO, BY THE
WAY, EXCLUSIVELY WITH CHRISTIAN
NIELSEN ABOUT HER RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND PRESSING
IMMIGRATION ISSUES.
>> GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMING TO THE SET
TONIGHT.
YOU HAD A BIG, FIERY HEARING ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY.
IT'S ALWAYS FUN.
SO THIS IS A BIG DAY FOR YOU.
KAMALA HARRIS DECIDED TO HIT YOU
ON THE ISSUE OF SEPARATING
CHILDREN FROM THEIR PARENTS,
LET'S WATCH.
>> YOUR AGENCY WILL BE
SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
>> WHAT WE WILL BE DOING IS
PROSECUTING PARENTS WHO HAVE
BROKEN THE LAW JUST AS WE DO
EVERY DAY IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
>> I CAN APPRECIATE THAT, BUT IF
THAT PARENT HAS A 4-YEAR-OLD
CHILD, WHAT DO YOU PLAN ON DOING
WITH THAT CHILD?
>> THE CHILD UNDER LAGOS TO HHS
FOR CARE AND CUSTODY.
>> THEY WILL BE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR PARENTS.
>> IT'S WHAT WE DO IN THE
UNITED STATES EVERY DAY.
>> Laura: IF THE IMMIGRATION
SOB STORY AS WE CALL IT ON THE
RADIO, WHICH IS NOT TO BE
DIMINISHED.
THESE ARE HEARTBREAKING
SITUATIONS.
HOW DO YOU AS DHS SECRETARY COME
BACK WITH THE EMOTIONAL PUSH ON
THIS?
HOW CAN YOU DO THIS AND YOU KEPT
SAYING BASICALLY THIS IS THE
LAW.
HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH THAT?
>> IT IS THE LAW, AS YOU KNOW
AND I HAD AN EXCHANGE LAST WEEK
WITH A DIFFERENT SENATOR THAT
TRIED TO CUT ME OFF SAYING THIS
IS YOUR PHILOSOPHY AND I SAID
IT'S NOT A PHILOSOPHY, IF THE
LAW.
IF YOU ENTER OUR COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY WE WILL REFER YOU FOR
PROSECUTION AND PROSECUTE YOU.
AT THE END OF EVERY SOB STORY,
73% BORDER ASSAULT, KATE
STEINLE, WHERE IS THE COMPASSION
FOR THE FLIP SIDE THE
CONVERSATION?
>> Laura: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DON'T GET THE SAME TREATMENT
FROM KAMALA HARRIS AND OTHERS
WHO WE WILL BE QUOTING TONIGHT
IN THE SHOW BECAUSE IT'S ALWAYS
A ONE-WAY STREET AND I THINK
THOSE WHO ARE CHARGED WITH
ACTUALLY ENFORCING THE LAW ARE
ALWAYS MEANT TO BE THE BAD GUYS
AND YET THE AMERICAN CITIZENS
ELECTED DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE
THEY WANTED THAT SITUATION WERE
REVERSED.
IT'S AMERICA FIRST.
YOU'VE ACTUALLY DONE A LOT AND A
LOT OF THIS DOESN'T GET
DISCUSSED.
H1B VISA ABUSE, THAT'S BRINGING
IN FOREIGN WORKER ABUSE.
WORKING WITH DOJ.
WORKING ON OTHER WAYS TO PROTECT
THE AMERICAN WORKER.
AT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
REALLY FRUSTRATING IS THIS
ASYLUM FRAUD.
WE'VE BEEN DOCUMENTING IT ON THE
SHOW.
WE HAVE AMERICAN LAWYERS FLYING
DOWN TO MEXICO COACHING CLIENTS.
THEY SAY IT'S ADVISING CLIENTS.
WHAT CAN YOU DO ON AN EXECUTIVE
LEVEL IF CONGRESS DOESN'T GET
OFF ITS BACKSIDE AND GET THIS
DONE?
>> IT'S REALLY FRUSTRATING, I
GOT TO BE HONEST.
I REALLY SHARE THE PRESIDENTS
FRUSTRATION ON THIS AND THAT OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE WAY THE SYSTEM WORKS RIGHT
NOW THE THRESHOLD IS SO LOW,
ABOUT 80% PAST THAT INITIAL
INTERVIEW BUT ONLY 20% ARE
GRANTED ASYLUM BY A JUDGE, WHICH
TELLS US THAT 80% OF THAT IS
EITHER JUST A FLAT OUT FRAUD OR
SOMEBODY WHO THINKS THEY CAN
COME HERE BECAUSE THEY WANT A
JOB HERE.
LET'S NOT ASSIGNMENT.
I WANT TO REUNIFY WITH MY
FAMILY, THAT'S NOT ASYLUM.
I JUST WANT TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES.
NOT ASYLUM.
WE HAVE LEGAL WAYS TO DO THAT
BUT IT'S NOT THROUGH ASYLUM.
>> Laura: WE HEAR THERE MIGHT
BE ANOTHER CARAVAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE WE GOT THE
NEW CARAVAN, A BIBLICAL, PEOPLE
ARE COMING UP AGAIN BECAUSE THEY
FEEL LIKE AS LONG AS THEY GET TO
THE BORDER THEY CAN GET INTO THE
COUNTRY AND THEY WILL ULTIMATELY
BE RELEASED, CORRECT?
OR ARE THEY NOT BEING RELEASED?
>> WE ARE METERING, WHICH MEANS
THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO LET THEM IN ON A
PARTICULAR DAY THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO COME BACK.
THEY WILL HAVE TO WAIT THEIR
TURN AND WE WILL PROCESS THEM AS
WE CAN, BUT THAT'S THE WAY THAT
THE LAW WORKS.
ONCE THEY COME INTO THE
UNITED STATES WE PROCESS THEM.
WE HAVE ASKED CONGRESS TO FIX
THIS LOOPHOLE.
IT'S A HUGE GAPING LOOPHOLE THAT
WE NEED TO FIX BECAUSE IT IS SO
ABUSED.
>> Laura: ONE OF THE OTHER
THING IS THAT I THINK IS VERY
FRUSTRATING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IS THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
THESE REPEAT BORDER CROSSERS,
PEOPLE WHO HAVE JUMPED THE
BORDER MULTIPLE TIMES, HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED, COME BACK INTO THE
COUNTRY AND YET THEY STILL GET
THE OH, MY GOSH, WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO ABOUT THE POOR
IMMIGRANTS, OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING SHATTERED BECAUSE OF THIS
ENFORCEMENT.
YOU HAVE ACTUALLY OVERSEEN A
HUGE INCREASE IN BORDER
ENFORCEMENT AND WORKPLACE
ENFORCEMENT, RAIDS AND SO FORTH,
WHICH I THINK ARE BEING WELCOMED
BY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, BUT
AGAIN, THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE HITTING YOU FOR
SHATTERING COMMUNITIES.
>> LET'S GO BACK TO KATE.
HOW SAD IS IT THAT THE CONGRESS
OF THE UNITED STATES CAN'T PASS
A LAW TO SIMPLY INCREASE
PENALTIES FOR CRIMINALS WHO HAVE
BEEN DEPORTED TO COME BACK?
THE HOUSE PASSED IT, WE CAN GET
THE SENATE TO PASS IT.
ALSO WE COMMUNITIES, WE JUST
BROKE THROUGH THAT HOUSE LAST
WEEK.
IF THE GENTLEMAN HAD DEPORTED
FOUR TIMES AND HAD FINAL ORDERS
OF REMOVAL FIVE TIMES AND WE ARE
STILL DEALING WITH HIM BECAUSE
WE CAN'T COMPLETELY -- THE
SYSTEM DOESN'T WORK.
YOU DEPORT HIM AND HE COMES
BACK, WHICH IS WHY AS YOU KNOW
WE NEED A WALL.
>> Laura: WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD AT THE
BORDER?
THAT WAS A BIG CONTROVERSY HERE
IN WASHINGTON.
I TRAVELED THE COUNTRY A LOT.
IT SEEMED AGAIN LIKE THE PEOPLE
ARE SAYING IT'S ABOUT TIME.
I HEAR THAT ON THE RADIO ALL THE
TIME.
PEOPLE CALLING IT, WHY DON'T WE
GET THE NATIONAL GUARD, WHY
DON'T WE GET EXTRA HELP?
YOU HAVE NEWS ON MORE TROOPS NOW
GOING TO THE BORDER, TELL US
ABOUT THAT.
>> VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
SUPPORT OF SECRETARY MATTIS AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
WE HAVE ABOUT 1600 NOW.
WITH OUR SECOND REQUEST WE WILL
HAVE ABOUT 2200.
ORIGINALLY WE WERE FOCUSED ON
BORDER PATROL SUPPORT BUT NOW
WE'VE EXTENDED IT SO WE WILL
SUPPORT THE FOLKS AT THE PORTS
OF ENTRY AND ARE INTEL AND
ANALYSIS.
IT'S A HUGE FORCE MULTIPLIER.
>> Laura: CALIFORNIA, JERRY
BROWN SAYING WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BE ASSISTING IN IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS ACTUALLY
DOING?
>> THEY ARE SUPPORTING CBP.
THEY ARE JUST DOING IT BEHIND
THE SCENES.
THERE ARE SPECIFIC THINGS THAT
WE WORKED OUT.
THEY ARE SUPPORTING.
WE WANT EACH GOVERNOR TO DO
MORE.
I TALK TO EACH GOVERNOR, TALK TO
THEM ABOUT ONCE A MONTH TO GIVE
THEM THE NEW BORDER FIGURES,
WHAT WE ARE DOING.
CALIFORNIA TO DO MORE.
>> Laura: WE JUST TALKED TO
BOB GOODLATTE ON THE SHOW AND
HE'S VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THESE
IMMIGRATION CENTRIST.
I CALLED THEM LIBERAL
REPUBLICANS, WHO ARE PUSHING
THIS NEW DACA AMNESTY RIGHT NOW
AND TRYING TO PUSH THIS
DISCHARGE POSITION, IT RAN
THROUGH THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AT LEAST.
WHAT DO YOU WANT CONGRESS TO DO
AND THIS PRESIDENT TO GET THIS
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT DONE THE
RIGHT WAY IN ORDER TO SATISFY
HIS PROMISES TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN VERY CLEAR ON THIS.
IT'S VERY EASY.
WE NEED A WALL.
WE NEED TO CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES
AND THEN WE NEED PERSONNEL AND
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED.
APPREHENSION WITHOUT DETENTION
REMOVAL IS NOT BORDER SECURITY.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE THE BEDS.
WE GOT TO BE ABLE TO APPREHEND,
DETAIN, AND THEN REMOVE.
THAT'S JUDGES, LAWYERS,
DETENTION BETS.
IT'S A VERY EASY FORMULA TO HAVE
BORDER SECURITY.
BORDER SECURITY IS PART AND
PARCEL TO THE SOVEREIGNTY OF A
NATION.
>> Laura: HOW MANY PEOPLE,
ABOUT CROSSED THE BORDER LAST
MONTH IN THE UNITED STATES?
FAMILY UNITS.
>> TAKE THE ORIGINAL CARAVAN
LOCATION.
WE HAD ABOUT 100,000 PEOPLE THAT
CROSSED THAT PORT OF ENTRY EACH
DAY.
MOST OF THAT IS LEGAL TRAFFIC
BUT AGAIN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
MILLIONS, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE THAT CROSS.
ABOUT 1.1 EACH DAY BETWEEN THE
TWO BORDERS.
IT'S A LOT OF TRAFFIC, BUT
BURIED IN THERE OF COURSE ARE
THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING TO ABUSE
THE SYSTEM.
IT'S A BROKEN SYSTEM.
WITH GOT TO WORK WITH CONGRESS.
CONGRESS HAS GOT TO CLOSE THESE
NOBLES.
>> Laura: 203% INCREASE IN
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSINGS FROM
MARCH 2017 TO MARCH 2018 I THINK
MY FAMILY UNITS OVERALL.
IT'S A HUGE INCREASE.
WHY?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> A COUPLE THINGS.
IF SOME OF THE LOOPHOLES ARE
THEY KNOW IF THEY CROSS BETWEEN
THE PORTS OF ENTRY NOTHING WILL
HAPPEN.
IF THEY BRING KIDS THEY WILL BE
RELEASED.
THE KIDS WILL BE RELEASED IN 20
DAYS UNDER A COURT CASE.
IF THEY ARE CRIMINAL THEY WILL
SERVE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME AND
UNDER A DIFFERENT COURT CASE
THEY HAVE TO RELIST THEM IN SIX
MONTHS BACK TO THE COMMUNITIES,
THE CRIMINALS.
IF THERE OTHER THAN MEXICAN WE
CAN PUT THEM IN EXPEDITED
REMOVAL IF THEY ARE CHILDREN
INVOLVED.
THEY KNOW BETTER THAN CONGRESS,
THEY KNOW BETTER THAN MOST OF
US, SO THEY KNOW THE LOOPHOLES,
THEY ARE EXPLOITING THEM.
>> Laura: ARE YOU ON THE
PRESIDENT GOOD NOW?
THERE WAS SOME CONCERN LAST
WEEK.
HE'S VERY IMPATIENT FOR CHANGE,
I'VE NOTICED THAT, MADAM
SECRETARY.
>> HE'S FRUSTRATED, AND RIGHTLY
SO.
CAN YOU IMAGINE, HERE IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SAYING I WANT TO SECURE THIS
COUNTRY.
AMERICANS MUST COME FIRST AND
CONGRESS IS SAYING WE DON'T HAVE
TIME, WE ARE BUSY, WITH GOT TO
GO ON RECESS.
>> Laura: YOU WERE HERE FOR